[Music]
let's let's get one more call in oh
i didn't know it was in oklahoma fine
what's up kyle in oklahoma
hey john how are you i was great until i
had to call an oklahoman but such i'm
just kidding how's it going man at least
it's not a houstonian right boo
if dude if h town would have been
awesome no yeah when you're in texas
when you grow up in texas oklahoma's
basically southern canada and it's well
yeah
most of
al qaeda lives so it's all good so
what's up dude
hey um so my wife and i have been
married for about five years we each
have a child from a previous life line
chip
and we've got a foster daughter as well
calling about our middle son
he's my step son my wife's biological
son but
i guess it was about four months ago
he was in his last week before christmas
break and his father was arrested for
child abuse
we got a phone call from dhs while he
was at school
and probably spent it was probably a
week before we even had a chance to talk
to his father again uh
he just kind of said you know the
lawyers advising that you know cut off
contact with the
with his son for right now
while they're doing their investigation
and whatnot and uh
i guess our question is
two part really it's do we kind of bring
this up to our eight-year-old son and
let him kind of know what's going on or
do we wait for him to start asking
questions and then just what kind of
words do we use when we're trying to
explain what happened here to him yeah
he's the little boy's lucky to have you
that's awesome well thank you
um and thanks for being proactive man
what a mess so is it physical sexual
abuse
uh physical abuse um our son's two
stepsisters weren't involved our son
wasn't involved but i mean obviously
he's been going over there and that kind
of environment yeah so so um
broad recommendation
every kid needs the bathing suit talk
the talk about adult touch and kid touch
and private parts and what's good touch
and what's not good touch and the only
people on all of the earth that will
ever touch your body
or they can never see parts of your body
are a doctor and mom and dad every kid
needs that so that's sexual abuse and a
safe place to mom and dad need to not
say things like uh and again i'm
teaching to the audience here not to you
um but every mom and dad don't say now
if anything happens you just come tell
us okay that's not how that works
parents have to engage that conversation
because the shame is so overwhelming for
a child right so that's sexual abuse
99 chance your son has seen this if not
experienced it is that fair yeah yeah
that's more than fair yeah okay so i
think um it's a very honest direct not
graphic conversation
that lets him know because what he's
going to do is he's going to slowly
start to put together that he's not
seeing dad and y'all are going to be the
bad guys
right
and
all kids
understand that they are both mom and
both dad that that's part of them
and so this conversation is gonna be not
that your dad did this awful evil thing
because to an eight-year-old then that
means part of me is awful and evil
it's gonna be i'm sorry it is that he
did an evil thing not that he's awful
and evil
right okay so because we're not gonna
connect identity to this eight-year-old
little boy cause he's gonna say well
then i'm capable of this type of evil
it's going have you all had
conversations about abuse your son has
suffered in the
past uh
no and up till i mean this we didn't
really have reason to suspect it i mean
we knew dad was you know kind of
short-tempered
and things like that this was pretty out
of character for him okay
so did he um
put into context did he shake kids did
he punch a kid like what happened throw
a kid up against the wall
yeah i don't know i know mom uh our
son's stepmom so dad's wife works night
shift and kind of all the story we got
was basically she came home the girls
had bruises on them
um
she sent them to school like that and
then the the school got involved and we
really hadn't had a chance to talk to um
his dad and stepmom about you know we
didn't we don't really have their side
of the story okay um stepmom
should also not to be
permitted to be around those kids either
ever again well
yeah they're uh they're actually going
through a divorce so that's but
that's great but she doesn't need to be
around those kids
the fact that she didn't ring the bell
that she pawned that off on the school
is nonsense those girls looked to her
for help and she didn't provide it
the school had to bail her out
she may or may not be
in contact with the kids right now i
don't know well i hope she's not hope
she has no access to those kids at all
um because she failed him she let him
down right
she got charged too so i mean i'm sure
there's something in place there so my
conversation with my eight-year-old
would be this
um
we need to have a serious conversation
with you and i would do it in a place
where that's safe
and i would do it as much as possible
with physical touch involved okay
um
i would i the conversation would be very
short and very direct and very honest
which is
your dad got in trouble
he may have we're not sure but he may
have hurt some people when he got angry
and we are going um
we're not going to be able to see him
for a little while
and
i would let my son ask any questions say
i don't have a lot of answers
um we don't know everything for sure but
we do know is
he's in trouble right now
and your sisters are safe and the police
are involved and when we know more we
will let you know
if it comes out that this is true and
this happened right beat them up etc
then
the conversation will be an age
appropriate
um not using words like abuse and
violent it will be
your dad hit your little sisters with
the closed fist on their legs and that's
never okay for a grown-up to hit them
and so they're not allowed to be around
him anymore and right now
we're not gonna allow you and i think
it's important for him to know that you
are setting boundaries even though he's
gonna hate you for him for right now
okay okay yeah we are protecting you
because that's our job and the the
police officers or the courts so
whatever one he's gonna understand um
have said that daddy can't be around
kids anymore and i know this is so so
sad
your daddy does love you
very very much and he's getting the help
that he needs etc and we'll go down that
road
but i think it's important for him not
just to dad suddenly start ghosting him
it's that daddy got in trouble
and he did some things when he was angry
that he shouldn't have and um
for right now we're not gonna we're not
gonna be able to see him
and let that be that makes sense okay so
we're gonna keep it very fast for your
friends very surface level what we're
not gonna do is go into 18 hours of
um
explanations and we love you and
we're going to demonstrate that love
through touch through hey let's go get
some dinner we're going to go out where
do you want to eat give him some
uh
this is really important give him a
moment of choice because you know what
you're gonna give him when everything he
just lost control you're gonna give him
a tiny tiny piece of control back
ah okay so where do you want to go eat
and more importantly where do you want
to get ice cream after we eat
all right and whose hand do you want to
hold mine or dad's
his dad's hands are huge but they're
scratchy and moms are soft well you get
to pick which one and so we're going to
right we're going to what music do you
wanna listen to in the car and he may
say nothing he may go silent he may go
he may have experienced this before
um maybe you ask him that question have
you ever experienced dad when he got
very very angry was it scary
and if he says no never then great cool
that may or may not be true but we're
giving him tiny pieces of control back
in little pockets
and it's gonna settle his sweet little
eight yards eight-year-old soul down a
tiny bit
um i don't think that i would mention
right now
without the presence of a counselor
that it was his sisters that got beat up
okay because he is going to then be
about trying to i've got to be with my
sisters and now you've got a whole other
thing going on
okay my guess is he's had to protect
them before
uh
okay and he may need to see sisters by
the way and if y'all can make that
happen in any shape form or fashion make
it happen
okay take them all to the movies
whatever but he may need to put eyes on
them and i wouldn't uh
i wouldn't take that from him if at all
possible if the courts allow that but
great great question so i rambled a lot
at you here's the old ultimate
underlying things in a summary facts are
your friends
state it clearly age appropriately in a
way that he can understand but do it in
a context of touch
somebody's hole in one hand mom's you've
got your hand on the back of his neck
that he feels safe
because his body's going to take off on
him
ask him has this ever happened to you
before do you know have you ever seen
daddy get angry
and if he doesn't want to answer that
great cool
the third thing is here's what we're
going to do now you're safe here with us
and then we're going to um sisters are
going to stay with some folks right now
and they're going to keep her them safe
and they're going to be
loving and where do you want to go eat
okay and then we're going to go from
there okay
all right kyle uh i take back all the
mean things i said about oklahomans
you've you've done your you've done your
your costs because you've done your
country well you've done your state well
um
man this we're this
your kids are lucky to have you brother
and the community's lucky to have you in
it
to everybody listening if there are kids
in your world whether they're your kids
or others
and they show up with bruises you stop
everything
cancel everything
and make the calls